there's more and more attention being
paid to Joe Biden seemingly struggling
to remember basic facts and saying
strange things of Joe Biden in the video
I'm gonna play for you today seems to
forget Barack Obama's name and instead
refers to him as the guy that I worked
for now I know that there are some
people in my audience who are going to
write in very mad saying David you are
perpetuating these conspiracy theories
about Biden the truth is if I don't talk
about this at this point I'm a hypocrite
okay when Donald Trump missteps and
appears to be cognitively compromised I
talk about it because it's serious the
president's cognitive abilities and the
cognitive state of the president is one
of the most important things and
figuring out is this person even
competent to potentially be President of
the United States with Hillary Clinton
there was a ton of fake stuff
Hillary has Parkinson's Hillary's on her
deathbed she will be dead within months
of being inaugurated if we elect their
president of the United States it was
bogus conspiracy stuff and I didn't
cover it with Trump we've had the
slurring speech trouble reading sniffing
confusion going to a executive order
signing and then leaving without signing
anything
walking off of Air Force One and his
limo is right in front of him and he
wanders off and has to be brought back
saying that he wants to look into the
oranges of an investigation multiple
times unable to just say I want to look
into the origins of the investigation
I've covered it because it's extremely
concerning Joe Biden is also seeming a
bit off let's look at video from a
fundraiser again this week where he
seems to forget Barack Obama's name
because they invaded another country
book on Crimea he's saying that it was
president my applause oh now I get that
anyone can forget a word or a name at
any time I get that but this sort of
strange thing especially when you just
look at Biden today and over the last
few months versus the Biden of 2012 when
he debated and crushed Paul Ryan for
example I said after both of the debates
this year that Biden seemed slowed down
he seemed low-energy he seemed not quick
on his feet if you go back and look at
video of when Joe Biden debated Paul the
much younger by the way Paul Ryan back
in 2012 Biden was quick he was sharp he
was running circles around Paul Ryan
Paul Ryan didn't stand a chance I mean
just that literally embarrassed Paul
Ryan he seemed different and if I
ignored this now I would be a hypocrite
because I do have questions about this
this is not anything to make fun of
there's nothing to make fun of about
Donald Trump's a possible cognitive
decline it's not a joke
we want to be sure that the person who
is the president or someone who might be
president is fully there cognitively
period I've never seen anything like
this with Bernie Sanders I've never seen
anything like this with Elizabeth Warren
she's younger it doesn't matter the
point is it's the behavior that we
should be talking about this is not
about political party this is not about
anything like that I don't know what to
make of this and I'm curious to hear
from you about it what do you think
about what's going on here with Joe
Biden are there now enough examples of
this that it rises to a level where we
should be asking more questions and be
concerned I want to hear from you